you
so thank you all for coming for those of
you didn't know the talk today will be
about billiards or any one of some
similar games did you play with the
billiard table outside you guys are a
bit young if you played billiards before
for those of you who haven't have you
played mini golf before for those of you
who haven't done either have you ever
looked in a mirror before yeah well the
mathematics behind all three of those
things is pretty similar so I want to
talk about them a little bit those who
have a played billiards have you ever
seen somebody do a trick shot where
they're sitting there and they hit the
ball off the wall and goes off another
wall and off another wall and something
goes where they wanted to go how do they
do that how do they guess it yeah well
it does recoil right the ball hits the
wall and goes off but but some you know
they're figuring it out they're figuring
out okay I'm gonna hit it off one wall
and it's gonna go off another wall and
off another wall but how am I figuring
out where it's going to go yeah whoo
those are some good words then perhaps
they perhaps they really apply here I'm
gonna tell you something about angles
okay let's think about angles for a
second so we have a billiard table I'm
just going to draw a part of it here's
the wall and here's a ball and the ball
hits the wall and we what's it going to
do is it gonna stop or is it going to go
out yeah hmm
a 90-degree angle like this anyway you
shoot it from the balls point of view
like this do you think it will form a 90
degree angle well let's try to think
about that let's try to take the ball
and put it really really almost parallel
for the wall okay it's almost parallel
to the wall and it hits the wall an
almost a 90 degree angle would be almost
straight down is that what the balls my
to do know if it's almost parallel to
the wall what's it gonna keep it when it
hits the wall it's gonna still be almost
parallel to the wall yeah more get more
of you yeah mm-hmm the angle that it
that it points with the walls gonna stay
the same yeah what do you want it's
going to be a mirror image yes those are
both exactly the right answer the angle
that it forms with the wall is going to
be exactly the same angle yeah what it's
symmetrical yes you're right there's
gonna be an exact symmetry there so
let's try to think about why that might
be true why might it formed the same
angle with the wall well let's let me
draw the picture so it's not so messy
okay here's the ball here's the wall and
now I'm gonna warn you that since we're
doing math we're ignoring a lot of
things okay in the real world the angle
that it leaves that might not be the
exact same angle that it hit can anybody
tell me why in the real world it might
not be the exact same angle yeah oh yeah
there could be impurities in the wood
which could cause that this might not be
a straight line well so what if you hit
the ball really really really weakly
what would it happen
what would happen it would just stop
right it wouldn't leave mm-hmm because
why it depends on how much it seems like
it would depend on how much force that
you would hit it with right if you hit
it if you don't hit it very strong very
strongly than it's not going to keep on
going it here's another thing a ball
isn't the point right a ball isn't the
point what's it shaped like a ball yeah
it might have spin if I hit the ball
off-center it's gonna have spin and who
knows what it'll do it's gonna be pretty
hard but since this isn't an advanced
physics lecture we're just gonna pretend
that the ball is a point and we're gonna
pretend that the ball is not slowing
down as it keeps on going what's making
that ball slow down does anyone know the
word yeah
friction right if you saw the board out
there the billiard board out there
especially if it has a lot of friction
why it's soft right it doesn't it
doesn't it'll make the ball go a bit
slower as it goes along on this soft
surface so we're gonna pretend that the
ball is a point and we're gonna pretend
that there's no friction so we're
playing on a billiard table that's made
of ice or something like that or an air
hockey table okay all right you guys
ever played air hockey right the
principle is also very similar and so
we're gonna ignore all the things that
are confusing us and just focus on the
things that are important here
one ball it's almost a point one wall no
friction right so we all know that it's
going to hit here and it's going to go
back this way now if there's nothing
slowing the ball down it's going to
leave at the same speed that it as the
speed but where it hit the wall if
there's nothing slowing it down and
nothing speeding it up it should leave
at the same speed right now that speed
has two parts it has an up-and-down part
and it has a sideways part okay
you see yeah you see that the speed has
how fast you're going to be up and down
direction and how fast you're going the
sideways direction when you hit the wall
two things happen well what happens to
the up-and-down speed in the beginning
you were going up what happens out after
you hit the wall you're going down
you're going down as fast as you were
going up nothing right what the what all
did is it exactly
put the up-and-down speed how about the
sideways speed it's the ball doing
anything it's to the sideways speed no
and so the up-and-down speed is stays
the same except the up turned into a
down the sideways speed stays the same
right so you guys go too low well those
of you who are not in high school go to
high school you'll say hey look what
does that mean let me draw this that
means that if you draw little lines
connecting the ball to the wall to the
wall that means that these Heights will
stay the same and these lengths will
stay the same that means that these
angles will be the same okay let's try
to think about it in a different way
okay you're sort of a strange way of
thinking about this problem okay and I'm
not gonna think about about a ball in a
wall anymore I'm gonna think about
something else okay so we can see that
the angle that you hit the wall is the
same as the angle that you left the wall
the angle that you hit the wall to
thanks the angle that you leave the wall
by think about speeds but here's sort of
another strange way of thinking about it
suppose this was a river okay and it
takes I'm suppose my drawing skills
aren't great and here you are and here's
some spot
suppose you want to go from where you
are now to the river get some water and
go to this spot okay and let's say that
you don't like to walk too much so you
want to figure out the shortest way of
doing it and you want to figure out the
shortest way of picking up some water at
the river and then getting to this spot
yeah and so one thing that you could do
is you could go straight down to the
river swim orbit you let the current
carry you and go straight up here but
suppose maybe the river okay let's put
some alligators and sharks in the river
so we're not swimming okay let's not
yeah yeah you'd want to go diagonal and
then dangle right it's see that seems
like the best idea right London sort of
it the first idea might have is to say
okay I'm gonna go down to the river
it'll walk a little bit and then I'll go
up well that probably won't be the
shortest Ray wait by the way what would
be the shortest way to get from this
point so let's call them with names a
and B what would be the quickest way to
get from A to B if you didn't have to
stop by the river a straight line yeah
what's the correct what's the shortest
route between two points a straight line
but we do have to stop by the river it's
a shame we can't walk in a straight line
we almost can yeah there you go so you
guys have some good ideas yeah
so you could go to be that would be one
idea and then go down to the river and
then go back up that seems like you're
backtracking a little bit maybe it's the
shortest it could be the shortest so
what idea would be to go to be go down
and go up another idea that I heard
would be to go diagonal but when you say
diagonal do you mean this diagonal or
this diagonal or this diagonal or maybe
this one which one do you mean mm-hmm
all of them are they all the same yes
yes to make it a wide from eight you
want this angle to be a right angle
maybe it would right angles turn up a
lot it could be yeah
mm-hmm okay
right what's it do what why why is that
it's doing it because of traffic or what
okay okay right oh yeah there you go
because it's not just how short the
route is it's how fast you're going
there right if there's traffic or the
speed load or there's a speed limit
except here there won't be any traffic
that's always good right so I mean
there's a river and there's walking but
you're - which is a shame but there's no
traffic so that's nice yeah
so that's a diagonal way of doing it
right under B and then go straight up is
it a lot longer how can we tell there's
how many different ways are there of
doing this five ten what how many
different ways
millions infinity can we check them all
should we check them all well we only
have an hour to do the lecture and so
infinity might be a lot to check let's
try to see if we can cut it down to one
yeah mm-hmm so I'm gonna tell you I'll
give you some measurements if I give you
some measurements can you figure it out
can you tell me what method you would
use to figure it out probably all right
let's give some numbers here's a and it
is do you mind if I use meters I'm still
not used to the feet system this is the
hundred meters from the river and here's
B and it is 60 meters for the river and
between this point at this point there
are 237 meters
pretty much it's not as long as you
think but yeah that's a little bit of a
walk yeah if I would do one oh but I
don't get to choose where a is a is
where I am right now so this is sort of
this is meant to be the shortest
distance from a to the river this is the
straight down line so we're getting a
lot of ideas here I want to explore this
diagonal idea but before that I want I
just want to bring up one point do you
remember what's the shortest distance
between any two points a straight line
the shortest distance between any two
points is a straight line right in this
problem we can't do this in a straight
line but we would sure like to right so
let me give you a trick okay let's just
draw something imagine that the river is
a mirror okay let's take something
magining but let's imagine that this is
a mirror okay here's a you're standing
at a and when you look in the mirror you
see yourself where do you see yourself
yeah in front of you right over here
okay there's your mirror image here's B
where does B see itself over there right
a bit closer to the mirror
okay so let's give them names you're
probably right I agree let's do this a
bit further so math we like to put
little decorations on the thing so we'll
call this B with a little decoration
this one is a with a little decoration
okay
when you walk from a to the river and
then to B when you walk from A to the
mirror to gets a mirror water and the
walk to B let's draw what I want to do
is I want to draw my path from A to the
mirror and then instead of drawing my
path from the mirror to be I'll just
follow what it does in the reflection
yeah mm-hmm yeah that's exactly right
that's exactly right what's the shortest
distance from A to this little B in the
mirror yeah a straight line right the
shortest this is from a to this point in
the mirror is a straight line except
we're not really walking in the mirror
right we can't do that
that shortest distance is a straight
line okay except what will happen now
then when the wall hits a mirror here it
will it will bounce it will bounce to B
but it actually does is this right in
the reflection it will look like this
right just like when you say touch a
mirror with your hand it looks like the
thing with your mirror is that the
mirror image is forming a straight line
with your finger in the mirror to look
like this in real life it'll look like
this or as close as real life is to
drawing on the board right this is the
shortest path here's the shortest path a
path that forms a a straight line right
we took a straight line path and then we
just took this piece off broke it off
and we flipped it over
we didn't want what's it called when you
look at something from your originate
reflection right
you learn about reflections in school
this is a reflection all right hmm
that's even better
okay this is a mirror image a reflection
that's the shortest path any other path
will not form a straight line okay any
other path when you look at its mirror
image will not be a straight line so it
won't be the shortest path this is the
shortest path okay and since it's a
reflection what do you what can you say
about the angles yeah hmm I think I'm
not remembering like so I'm just saying
that this and bit are this and this
vertical angles these aren't quite
vertical right there they are right
because they're not at the intersection
of two lines right but this angle and
this angle you mean these two so this is
the angle that you hit let's call it a
your right this one and this one are
vertical angles so that's a and since
it's a reflection this is also a okay so
here ya
this one in this one or this one in this
one they're not ninety degrees
they don't while they're both the same
if they added up to ninety degrees in
there we're both the same what would
each one of them have to be 45 except
sometimes it can you imagine moving this
a a bit down or a bit up you wouldn't
always hit it a 90 to five degrees at a
45 degree angle right you'd hit it you
can hit at different angles it's a good
guess because it looks a lot like 90 in
my picture right it looks exactly 90 in
my picture but I think that's the more
of a problem with my picture they have
to be the same angle because they're
just reflections of each other they're
just mirror images of each other and so
if they added up 90 they would have to
each be 45 or they don't you can hit it
a different angle and so this is telling
you something interesting about yeah so
if they were each 45 then this would be
a 90 degree angle and sometimes they
will be and sometimes they won't it
really depends on what angle you hit the
ball the ball at the wall at and so
here's kind of an interesting thing
about this billiard table when you hit a
billiard ball at the wall and it
reflects off wherever it ends up it
shows the shortest path to do it of all
the possible different ways of going
from where you started to where you
ended up it shows the shortest one and
that sort of raises the question well
how did it know to choose the shortest
path it didn't calculate all the paths
right didn't think about all of them but
somehow it miraculously chose well then
it's not a miracle but it's it sort of
amazingly chose the shortest possible
path to do this right
and so the basic law of physics that
applies to billiards is when you hit a
wall at an angle you leave at the same
angle rephrasing it in this way is the
way you can say when you hit a wall and
you pretend that the wall is a mirror
then it looks like you keep on going in
a straight line your mirror image keeps
on going in a straight line okay but you
don't really right you hit the wall you
keep on going somewhere else but in the
mirror it looks like you're going in a
straight line right so this applies to
lots of things in the real world well it
certainly applies to billiard tables or
air hockey tables or mini golf tables
but it applies to anything that reflects
off another thing anytime light hits a
surface and reflects off it does this
yes all right so you're taking it wait
so are you trying to take you try to
look at that look at the mirror image
okay
so it thinks it's so if you have a
camera with one of those fancy things
that sets the focus so it would focus on
so if you could do that would focus on
b-prime yeah yeah all right so this is
this sort of principle applies to
anything where light reflects off a
surface as well so this is something
that's really useful in the real world
knowing how things reflect is really
useful in the real world let me just
give you an application of this sort of
idea that's completely different from
billiards
does anybody here get TV with a
satellite dish or have you ever seen a
satellite dish that gets TV yes what do
they look like
there's a satellite this look like
mm-hmm a tilted plate except it's got a
little curvature to it right it's curvy
yeah it's like a bowl with sticks coming
out right looks like this and then
there's a little sticks coming out and
then there's a little cup over here
right and it's standing on something
right why is it shaped like that and
what's this shape it's round is it a
circle what is it with this curvy shape
is it half a sphere it looks like it
right or you're not quite half because a
little bit less but it looks like it
would be a sphere that's a good guess
but it it turns out it's not yeah it
looks like it's part of a crescent but
it's actually not well a dome a crescent
there these are all names for something
that has right that's kind of circular
well and then has anybody ever heard of
a parabola yeah so this turns out to be
a parabola you know why it's a parabola
a parabola has a really neat property to
it what's the property of a parabola
well let me draw this Cup if you shine
light straight at a parabola it'll
bounce off and no matter where you shine
the light straight at the parabola it
always bounces off to the same spot and
you know what's in that spot this little
cup always bounces up so this is some
sort of a neat property of bouncing off
and problems and always bounces off to
that same spot oh so what the this
satellite dish does is well what's why
they're called satellite dish because
somewhere in outer space there's a
satellite there's this little dot in
outer space really really far away
broadcasting a signal to earth and what
you do is you point the sound in this
dish right at the satellite and it takes
all of the transmission from the
satellite and focuses it all in one spot
there's a lot of telescopes out there
that work on the same principle you take
light from one direction you focus it
all in one spot
everything bouncing back to this spot
this receiver is are things that are
coming straight from the satellite it's
not getting any noise it's just getting
things that came from the satellite all
bounced down to over here so when you
see a satellite dish next time you can
think oh that's a parabola and it's a
parabola well it's not quite a parabola
because it's 3-dimensional right it's
not a 2-dimensional thing but that's a
parabola it's a parabola for the exact
reason that we know something about how
reflection works with a parabola let's
go back to billiards for a second yes it
does seem to do that except the cable
box doesn't have as much interference as
you would with a satellite dish with a
satellite dish there's thousands and
thousands of satellites in outer space
and there's lots of other signals
bouncing around the air so you really
want to focus something so you're just
getting that satellite you don't want
anything else inside the house where
there's a cable box there's less there's
less interference so you can have
something that's not very directional
right when you threat when you push the
button on the remote it's not actually
emitting it necessarily in a small beam
it might be going but I don't really
know how the physics works there so so
so let's go back to or how the
engineering works there yes it's a bit
much better work so let's go back to the
billiards for a second I want to go back
to this notion of when you hit a wall in
the mirror it looks like you keep on
going straight
so here's a nice problem and this is a
problem really only a mathematician
would think about okay opposed we
weren't playing billiards on a
rectangular table we will get back the
rectangular type is table next but
suppose we weren't playing on a
rectangular table
suppose we had two infinite lines and
they formed a 60-degree angle and this
is where we were playing billiards on an
infinite billiard table that looked like
a bit of a triangle and they formed a
60-degree angle okay and now I have a
billiard ball and I hit it at the wall
what will it do it'll bounce off right
and here's my question to you you hit
that ball really hard and you wanted to
bounce off lots and lots and lots of
times what's the biggest amount of times
what's the greatest amount of times you
can make that ball bounce off walls yeah
okay
so do you think but do you think you
think I could hit it off the wall a
hundred times
how about two thousand more than one
hundred you think I could hit it
infinitely many times oh no definitely
there are reflections right it will
reflect off the wall so let's hear
people's guesses what's the biggest
amount who says in fit infinitely many
times who says less than a hundred let
me show you why okay let me show you why
you can't hit it off lots of times
alright you hit the ball off the wall in
the reflection what does it look like it
keeps on doing it goes straight it
really will go into zig zag but let's
pretend this is a mirror so it'll look
like it keeps on going straight and then
it will keep on going it'll hit this
wall and then it will in this mirror
it'll look like it keeps on going what
will keep on look like he keeps on going
straight 360 degree angles form a 1 180
degree angle and maybe they'll hit the
wall again and again and again but if
you keep on reflecting how many 60 is
can you fit into a whole circle you can
fit 3 6 60 s into a whole circle and if
you draw draw what the wall does it'll
keep on going in a straight line forever
there are six lines that are formed by
the walls right one two real ones and
one two three four pretend ones in the
reflection
how many times can this line hit these
six walls
well it could hit them but it a line
hits another line of how many points at
one point or zero it can give each of
these lines one or zero times what's the
biggest amount of times it can hit a
wall well what's the biggest amount of
times it can hit any of the walls in
this table say it's certainly less than
seven right it can't be more than six
because in the reflection it won't hit
it won't it actually won't hit all six
of them either right but it certainly
can't hit all it can't hit any of these
lines more than once so that most it can
hit six walls that's really
counterintuitive
most people here thought he could go
infinitely it could hit the walls
infinitely many times because our
intuition says oh I'm gonna do let's
erase these pretend walls our new
tuition says oh I can do like this and
it'll zigzag in somehow and do some
crazy stuff but it won't it'll hit at
most six walls yes if you're just going
like this the same logic applies at most
it'll be less in six walls but it'll hit
in most six walls yes
so he won't keep on hitting it one point
you know what it's gonna do it's gonna
start going like this in a way that
doesn't that it no longer hits anymore
walls but it can't if it keeps on going
in if in the mirrors it keeps on going
in a straight line in a straight line
you can hit it most six mirrors it will
keep on going straight and just keep on
getting further and further away from
the walls it doesn't seem like an that
doesn't seem right to us that right that
seems like the wrong thing you can you
might think oh can it go around in a
triangle right but it actually can't it
can just keep on hitting a few walls and
then they'll just start bouncing off in
a way yes to the vertex did it might if
you started it there I mean you could
make it go out this way depending on
where you start on what angle you hit it
but if I don't know what if I don't care
what angle I started with or what angle
I hit it I hit it with then there's no
telling where it will go in the end
right yeah
if I make this angle not a 60-degree
angle
so if you made the angle exactly zero or
very close to zero then you would be
heading into the vertex and really our
law of physics doesn't actually apply
there but we don't know what happens
when you hit at an angle and you're just
gonna get it so for our purposes you'll
just get stuck if you hit the corner in
the natural billiard table there's
pockets in the corner corner if you hit
the corner the ball just leaves this
feeling if we're going at exactly zero
you'll just get stuck in this little
corner over here yeah so yeah exactly so
if it was one degree than it would be
360 it's a strange question to ask what
would happen if your angle was PI
degrees or some number where no matter
how many times you multiplied it
wouldn't close up the full circle that's
sort of a different more difficult
question let's go back to an actual
billiards table now and for the sake of
my drawing skills let's pretend that the
billiard table is a square
and let's try to answer or start
answering some of the questions there
that are all in the actual billiard
table out there so here's a billiard oh
let me make it a little bit smaller
here's a billiard table and here's our
ball it starts off at point a and I want
to make it hit point B well that seems
pretty easy right it seems pretty easy I
would just hit in a straight line what
would happen if I'd want to hit from A
to B but bounce off this wall what would
I do
yeah I would make a mirror image about
what about which one of these sides
would I mirror about the side you want
to hit and what would I be trying to hit
right so I would reflect it over okay I
reflect I would reflect I could reflect
a over as well so it would be a bit
further what am I trying to hit in a
straight line I'm trying to hit the
mirror image and if I would do this it
would bounce back okay that's right and
what if I wanted to go what if I wanted
to do it some more what if I want to hit
if I want to go off this wall and then
off another wall say off this wall and
then hit B can you imagine a shot that
goes bang bang and then hits B what
would I do then mm-hmm so I would yeah I
want to get on top of me but how would I
do it kick can you mend serves a crazy
shot but I can do it on the board
because I'm good at drawing on with
chocolate suppose I wanted to do it on a
billiard table how would I do it yeah
more force would be the right thing but
what if I was trying to figure out
exactly where I wouldn't hit it - yeah
hmm I would reflect again
here's that be reflected again and if I
aim my shot over here right if I aim my
shot over here and you look at this
straight line well what does it do in
the billiard table first it hits this
wall and then it will hit the next wall
and then it will hit B and it will go
right past me but let's put one of those
one of those holes and B so the ball
will just fall in the net there can you
imagine
yeah all right so where's C and so if
you want to hit if you want to hit two
points that becomes a more complicated
question it becomes are they in the
straight line from each other right that
because that's actually it's a good
question but it's somewhat more
difficult than doing this okay it's a
good question and now my next question
which sort of lates into some slightly
different areas well now I have this
method if I know I want to reflect off
this wall and then this wall and then
this wall and then that wall I know how
to do it I just keep on reflecting but
suppose I wanted to hit off a thousand
different walls I wanted some shot that
hit off a thousand different walls but I
have to reflect a thousand times and
start figuring things out in order to
understand the system so probably I
would except I want to show you
something kind of neat okay I want to
show you something kind of neat about
the billiard table and so let's let's
draw our billiard table again
and to avoid confusion let's give it
sides names so this will be side a this
will be B this will be seeing this will
be D if I reflect it what do I get
what's up what's up here an imaginary D
and what's over here hey yeah what's
over here C and let's reflect this one
what's over here a and on the bottom is
a B and over here is up over here is up
B and the mill there's a C and if I do
maybe one more reflection up here is a B
and over here is up okay
and look at look at this over here
season these kind of went away like you
see that there's no Co if you look at
the big square that you get that you got
there's no season D's on this side this
side just has two A's the site has two
A's the site knows to B's and the site
has to B's okay see it and now if you
think about it this point up here in the
mirror image what point is it in my in
my original billiard table it's this
point over here and this point is this
point and this point is this point at
this point at this point at this point
is this point you see I have a square
and if I try to remember everything in
my say if I try to remember my in my in
my big square which point each point was
in my original billiard table I get this
sort of visit I get this sort of thing
that this point is this point and this
point is this point at this point is
this point at this point is this point
have you ever played one of those
computer games where say there's a worm
and it has to eat dots and when it goes
off the top of the board it comes back
right down on the bottom again and when
it goes off the side it comes out of the
other side yeah I did not those
still existed yeah this is something
similar to that right this point over
here is the same point as this point
over here if you imagine that if you
imagine playing that little worm game in
this in this screen if you went out here
you would come back right over here okay
now as mathematicians we like to think
about that a little bit and we like to
say the following suppose we had let's
draw what we actually have here we have
a big square and we know that this side
this whole side is the same as this side
when we go out here we get out here so
let's call them by names as helman the
site X and it's the same as this side
and the top is the same as the bottom if
you leave out the top you get out of the
bottom well it's a complicated series of
rules to remember I have a square if I
go out at the top I get out the bottom I
go out the left I got the right I got
the right guy at the left that sort of
complicated is there one sort of object
that we could have that would sort of
would explain what this rule is well
yeah so we're identifying opposites
you're right we are saying that
opposites opposite sides are the same
can you imagine that this is a piece of
paper imagine this is a piece of paper
and I want to say that this point is the
same as this point at this point is the
same as this point well one way of
saying that would be I'm yes question
yeah so what we have set yes
you would fold it right if you wanted to
say the two things are the same you'd
say let's just glue them together but if
you want to say two things are the same
two points are the same let's just glue
them together if they're the same what
would happen if you took this paint
piece of paper and you glued the X to
the X what would you get a cylinder
right if you glued the X to the X glue X
to X what do you get you get a cylinder
and the top of the cylinder is a why and
the bottom of the cylinder is a why
except we haven't finished glowing
because Y is the same as Y so you have
the cylinder this would be somewhat hard
with paper right but it imagine it's
sort of rubber or something like that
that you can what would you get if you
blew the top it would be a donut
right can you imagine that if you have
that if you have a cylinder right
imagine this being made out of dough or
something if you have a cylinder and you
took the top of it you glued it to the
bottom but would you get a torus a donut
right so in English we mostly say we
mostly say donut the mathematical word
for this is a torus okay it comes from
the same Latin root as tornado or torque
if you're applying torque to something
it means to spin to turn okay and so one
way of thinking about billiards in a
square table in the rectangular table
it's thinking about straight lines in a
torus that allows us to connect this
table that we're playing with to some
really strange object torus let's try to
do this now let's try to use a sort of
same idea suppose something else by the
way maybe before I do then before I do
that maybe let's understand let's
understand a little bit yes yes you can
get from every point to every other
point and what's more here's another
little thing that you can understand for
this foot a torus what's this let's call
this point P okay let's call it P could
be another point over here the same
point
probably view a different point okay if
you connect these two with the line so
let's get an actual straight line and
you hit the billiard at that angle it's
gonna return back to where it started at
the same angle what will the billiard
keep on doing around and around and
around and around so it's so acts like
this all the two sides together but what
I'm saying here is in a billiard table
that's square you can hit the billiard
in a certain way but it'll just keep on
doing the same path again and again and
again and again and again they'll keep
on going around and around and around
and around repeating itself it's kind of
an interesting question the
mathematicians like to ask if you give
me a billiard table and maybe it's not a
square anymore maybe it's a different
shape this is a game that mathematicians
like to play if I give you a different
billiard table that's not a square and I
hit the ball can I make it go back
around and around and around and around
it's called the periodic orbit probably
not if you have sort of a round the
billiard table if you just if you need
to take sort of a crazy guy with and
give him a saw and come to build a
billiard table and build some kind of
crazy billiard table maybe you won't be
able to do that who knows
and so one question the mathematicians
like to ask is okay let's hope playing
billiards in squares or rectangles is
nice and easy let's do an even simpler
shape let's play billiards and triangles
right rectangles nice but a triangles
nicer it has less sides this is true in
a triangle can we find so the
mathematical word is a periodic a
billiard orbit that means you hit the
ball and it keeps on going forever in
the same path repeating itself over and
over again yeah
triangle going to draw that's probably
going to become it looks like you but
yeah that triangle looks like it
actually has that orbit in it it might
how about this triangle I don't know
so here's the right the answer to this
is for some triangles nobody knows well
we don't know here but the the
mathematical community doesn't know any
and doesn't know either yeah
so it's the same idea it's it's like the
Earth orbits the Sun and goes back
around in the same in the same path
again and again and again
the mathematical word for an orbit
normally means you do something and you
track you do something some in some
mathematical system you're imagining and
you track what it does over time just
like the Earth orbits the Sun over time
it's a tracking of what something does
and so a billiard orbit is filling it
and watch what it does and in triangles
the best that anybody knows is if all
the angles in the triangle are less than
100 degrees then there's the mat then
there's an orbit that goes around and
around okay but if any of the angles is
more than 100 degrees and it's anybody's
guess but let me just this last thing
let me show you that in some triangles
it's easier than others
maybe the penultimate thing not last
that's right before last here's a nice
triangle what's a nicest triangle you
can think of oh yes say it out loud
equilateral triangle yes that seems to
be the ice it's an example of an
isosceles triangle right an equilateral
triangle has how angles that are all
equal to 60 degrees 60 60 okay
and let's try to do the same trick that
we did before reflecting or reflecting
reflecting and reflecting reflecting see
if we get the same kind of shape okay so
we reflect once and we reflect again and
that picture reflects itself over right
and then we close up and if we kept them
reflecting the triangle retouch we would
get this if we label the sides of the
triangle ABC we'll see that this is a
and this is a right and if this was B
then this was B and this will be B as
well okay and this will be C and this
will be C how many parallel sides so we
have something like before where we had
a picture of a square with sides
identified except now we have a what
what kind of shape is this a one two
three four five six a hexagon and this
hexagon has parallel sides and the
parallel sides are the same we do the
same trick that we did with the square
I'll try gluing what well can you
imagine having a hexagon piece of paper
and gluing the sides and we could what
what do we get well this is more
complicated right let's draw a hexagon
again so here's a hexagon
and we're low well that's not a pretty
hexagon it's a pretty ugly actually kind
but this is a and this is a this is B
this D this is seeing this and when you
go out here you come over here yeah so
then you you might get a dodecahedron
you won't but it seems like a good guess
here's something that you do can you
imagine taking this triangle over here
and cutting it out with scissors now B
goes to B is the same as B so we can
glue these B's to these B's and get a
that triangle over here so I cut it out
of here
with scissors and I glued it where it
goes over here and then I cut out this
triangle up from the bottom see this
triangle over here and and you put it
next to C and what do I get now a square
and this was an A in it well this is a
lot simpler this is very similar to what
we had before the top goes to the bottom
and the bottom goes to the top that's a
cylinder and then we have to glue the
sides so what you see here is going the
sides with a little twist
if this twists the sides a little but
you will still get donut you'll still
get it done it billiards on this
triangle are the same as billiards on
the square
it doesn't matter they're just straight
lines on a donut that one has periodic
orbits this one has periodic orbits it's
the same thing and so maybe before we go
let me just if you looked at the bill at
the billiard table outside there's a
picture on it I didn't have time to talk
about this I just want to talk about
something really quick so another
interesting question the mathematicians
sometimes ask themselves is well in a in
a regular billiard table if I start the
part of the ball of point a and I want
to hit it to point B I can do that
because I just aim it right at point B
and I shoot it
and so an interesting question could be
can you build a billiard table where
there's two points that you can't hit
each other with started ain't you want
to get to be but you can't do it no
matter what you do no matter what angle
no matter how hard you hit the ball you
can't do it yeah so they you could try
to make them really far away you could
try to make a maze right and and make it
all crazy and go like this like this but
this like this like this like this like
this and go all around and say okay
here's my bill your table I'm going to
put one ball over here and one ball over
here if why oh well if you could do that
that would be great
that's a good if you had yeah that's
true but we're pretending our ball is a
point you're right you could also make
two different billiard tables and put it
what and to have a and one of them and
be in the other you could put a date
between these are really good ideas but
suppose yeah
if you apply if you kept amazed then yes
if you tilted that would be a problem
yeah
and so these are good suggestions but so
I just want to say that yeah yeah one
more why all right but that only
reflects to the focus if you hit it
straight on not it doesn't reflect at
that point at any angle only if the
angles that are sort of going straight
into the parabola
no it'll the parabola itself is convex I
mean said any point can hit any other
point with a straight line you have to
mess it up with some kind of maze like
quality
it looks like you're right it looks like
it would be impossible to hit something
there into something there but maybe if
you hit it really strong enough and hits
the ball the wall enough times it might
get from here to here it's possible
right it could bounce bounce bounce
bounce bounce bounce bounce also so
let's talk about spouts bounce bounce
backs maybe like a pinball yeah one more
suggestion and because we have to close
yeah but you could still hit it at a
straight line through the cube you think
this is this is pretty good it looks
impossible and so if it's too small for
the ball I agree it's impossible but
we're pretending that our ball is a tiny
little point if it's too small you're
right you won't be able to yeah you did
solid ramp and hit Delta you can put all
kinds of obstacles you could place a cat
in there the things away or
so let me just tell you the answer so it
was unknown until I think 96 whether you
could do that and if you look at the
billiard table outside mathematician
they took ours he found an example of a
table and two points where you can't get
from one to the other and if you think
about that's a hard thing to show it you
have to show that no matter what angle
you shoot it at you're not gonna get
from one point to the other no matter
how long you let it go another way of
thinking about this is if you put a
source of light in point a and the walls
of the billiard table are made of
mirrors the point view will be
completely dark no light will reach
point B and so I suggest that you look
at it anyway out it except it doesn't
so if the ball if the light is placed
exactly at that point and you shine it
none sign it out a point a nun will
reach point B that's what this guy
showed and that point they will be in
the shadow you don't buy it
you don't believe me so it's not just no
it's not a laser pointing one in one
direction it's a it's a source of light
that goes in all directions no matter
what direction you go in but like from a
will never ever ever reach point B
that's why it's so hard to show this not
even a little bit of light will reach
point B point B will be all dark I agree
it's sort of hard to believe right if
you say it that way that's the nature of
mathematical proof if you if somebody
can actually sit if somebody can sit
down and show it with me the unless you
have magical powers point B will be dark
all right any questions all right